welcome to 100 seasons of gridiron
Heights maybe nobody noticed the but
thing red iron Heights began in 1920 as
the propaganda but the show didn't gain
popularity until its 1950s breakout star
I'm Johnny Unitas see and I shoot really
well yeah I had a Johnny Unitas crew
iron Heights lunchbox growing up who did
it the question was how do you feel
about the Niners loss oh I stopped
feeling things a long time ago the 80s
and 90s featured more beloved characters
time don't forget to watch the old
diamond Heights right after this go why
can't I get a room I never really liked
my character on the show and while
several Lost episodes have been banned
over the years the show has lasted 100
seasons thanks to the many classics
where's your vote my congrats card
hello youngsters if you enjoyed this
moving picture and would like to watch
more simply subscribe by sending all
your personal information exactly three
American cents to 100 grid iron Heights
way thank you and remember only we can
take down the commies